one of the big reasons Big Ang came on  the show to do the interview was to get  this last final utterance out that she  wanted people to know how dangerous  smokiness and I think everyone knows  that but to look at someone you respect  and have watched say it right to your  face as they're dying is very powerful  dr. oz reflects on his emotional  interview with late mob wife star Big  Ang the episode aired just two days  before she lost her battle with cancer  sometimes I feel at home I'm gonna be  fine then sometimes I just don't desire  the big legacy she's leaving us the  reason she came on the show was to make  sure everyone knew that cigarettes had  taken her life I stay positive I try to  stay positive I look at my kids and my  grandchildren and I know how much they  need me she was scared I think she knew  the end was grasping at her that she was  looking over the abyss of death the  darkness down there that we all fear and  she knew that it was close  you